2020 was a crazy year during it we had a
global pandemic literally the entire
world ground to a halt governments
around the world went ahead and shut
down their economies they mandated
people sit inside and try to prevent the
spread of the virus well when all of a
sudden you slow down the velocity of
money you grind these economies to a
halt you say that there is no ability to
go to work or to go and participate in a
normal way you have to do something
because investors get scared those
investors got real scared in march of
2020 when they got scared all of a
sudden they started to sell every asset
it's called a liquidity crisis during a
liquidity crisis an investor looks at
their entire portfolio and they say what
do i own that i can sell today so that i
can get dollars the dollar is safe the
dollar is strong i want to hold dollars
in times of uncertainty and so those
investors started to sell every single
asset they had in their portfolio that
had a liquid market they held stocks
they sold them they held gold they sold
them if they had bitcoin they sold them
anything they could sell to get dollars
they were doing it equities went down
about 25
gold was down about 15
bitcoin dropped 50 percent in a single
day whenever you have a massive sell-off
in the market and then you have that
overlaid with the uncertainty of running
a business and having to actually get
rid of employees and costs or whether
they're labor or their actual production
cost now you have fear setting it you
have this ability where businesses and
their employees do not know the future
at that moment in march of 2020 the
federal government and also the treasury
and the federal reserve all came
together they had a bunch of discussions
and they finally decided they were going
to take action in a variety of ways this
began the great manipulation of the
monetary and fiscal policy what we saw
were two emergency rate cuts where we
brought interest rates down to a zero
rate environment in the u.s we also saw
the printing of trillions of dollars and
it was stuffed in every corner of the
financial system at the same time some
of that money some of those trillions of
dollars went to unemployment boost but
some of it also went to very exotic
elements of the financial system where
there was repo markets and all sorts of
other things that were occurring whether
it was through monetary or fiscal policy
they wanted to intervene they wanted to
step in they wanted to help but at the
same time they also said we have to give
direct support to people and so they
sent out stimulus checks those stimulus
checks ended up being hundred dollars in
the max in april of twenty twenty so you
could earn up to twelve hundred dollars
depending on your income in prior years
those twelve hundred dollars if you held
it today would be worth much less
inflation has been over five percent now
for a number of months that means the
rate of the price growth of various
goods in the economy has absolutely
exploded
but if you got that 1200 check as
stimulus and you put it into bitcoin a
finite asset an asset that cannot be
debased by anyone it is not controlled
by anyone and you held it till today it
would now be worth over 10 000 u.s
dollars that's right those stimulus
checks that 1200 check if you had taken
it you'd converted it from a fiat
currency that was going to be devalued
at historic pace and you converted it
into an asset that no one could debase
as a global store of value that 1200 is
now worth over 10 000
absolutely incredible to see once people
start to learn how do i actually store
value wealthy people have been doing
this for literally centuries they take
their currencies and they convert them
into hard assets whether it's real
estate or some other type of commodity
there's all sorts of strategies that
people employ a lot of it is
underwritten by what is their risk
profile what is their liquidity needs
and what is the ability to actually make
money what is the price appreciation
look like as well but now what we see is
we have this digital decentralized
currency that digital decentralized
currency has become a global store of
value it is accessible to billions of
people around the world and what people
were able to do is they were able to
take that 1200 check they were able to
convert it from that fiat depreciating
asset into an asset that cannot be
debased that asset is now trading at a
much much higher rate than it was
previously and so when you get that
price appreciation you not only get the
preservation of purchasing power but you
also get the appreciation of purchasing
power which is exactly what bitcoin has
done at high rates of inflation what we
saw investors do is they literally
dropped gold gold is down seven percent
on a nominal basis it's down double
digits on a real return basis and they
instead chose bitcoin as the inflation
hedge we saw paul tudor jones and q3 of
last year say if i am going to believe
that there's going to be high rates of
inflation i want to own inflation hedge
assets but i think that bitcoin is going
to be the fastest horse and so he
allocated a single digit percentage of
his portfolio to bitcoin ends up that
paul tudor jones was right he was
quickly followed with public
announcements from everyone from stanley
druckenmiller to a bunch of other
well-respected institutions and
individual investors but the beauty of
bitcoin is that it is available to
anyone literally individuals around the
world front ran all of these hedge funds
and wall street institutions for years
beforehand all you needed was an
internet connection you could go on to
the web and you could go ahead and you
could purchase bitcoin you could convert
some of your other assets into an asset
that cannot be debased by anyone so that
1200 check that went out in april 2020
is now worth over ten thousand dollars
you can sit around and you can complain
about what is going on from monetary or
fiscal policy
or you can learn exactly what wealthy
people do you can learn how they protect
their purchasing power how they
appreciate their portfolio and how they
continue to put themselves in a better
and better financial position over time
that's what bitcoiners have done and
that's what you can do twelve hundred
dollars april 2020 now with over ten
thousand dollars that's the beauty of an
asset that can't be debased by anyone
else